(energetic music)
- Feast Mode Hunger Squad, back at it again.
- We're gonna drive all over Los Angeles--
- And look for the best PB and J sandwich.
- But instead of our usual telephone,
we're gonna play literal telephone--
- But we will be telephoning
Keith, to ask where to go.
- Why is Keith in the
video all of a sudden?
Who cares! That's why!
We're mixin' it up!
And, because today feast-mode, for work,
gets to eat peanut butter.
And I'm jelly.
- If you haven't noticed, I'm white.
Therefore, I've eaten more
peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches than anything else.
- The most important thing
in a peanut butter and jelly sandwich is
peanut butter to jelly ratio.
- You may have noticed
that I am leaning against
the good ol' nacho wagon,
making it's second appearance
in feast-mode hunger squad.
- PB and J!
- Alright, get in the van, guys.
- Alright.
So we are on our way to
Mendocino Farms, right now.
- We're about to eat
peanut butter and jelly
on quinoa millet bread.
So basically, they don't put
the PB and J on their menu
cause they're hoping
that it's just gonna grow
by word-of-mouth.
- It's like a hidden item.
- Secret menu.
- And now we are telling the world.
- Mmm!
- Collin!
- The white bread version, thus far,
to me it has like the classic PB and J.
I love the flavor.
Love the crunch.
- Let's not sleep on the gluten-free.
It's really good.
It actually kinda tastes like PB and J
on like a Triscuit, or like a Wheat Thin.
- The ratio is actually perfect.
- [Collin] Yeah.
- It's a slightly more
jelly, than peanut butter.
Time to call Keith, guys?
- Hello, Keith.
- (laughing) Hello, Collin.
How are you?
- I'm fantastic.
- How was the kid's menu PB and J?
- Definitely one of the
best kid's menu PB and J's
I've ever had.
- Well, that's incredible.
Now I'm sending you somewhere
where you can actually
order of the adult menu.
You're headed to Joan's on Third.
- We're going to Joan's on Third!
- I just ordered our four
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches.
- Yum.
- [Dark-haired male] Alright.
- Joan's on Third decided
to get all LA on us,
and say we can't shoot
without a location sign-off
from blah-blah, what-what.
We're eatin' in the van!
- What have you done in this
van, other than eat in it?
- You don't wanna know, Steven.
- (laughing) Okay! Movin' on.
- So they gave us these
dainty, delicious-looking
little peanut butter and jelly sandwiches.
They smell good.
They have good weight to them.
- Already, off the bat,
it seems like it has
too much peanut butter.
- But it really isn't like, that special.
Like it doesn't taste like
gourmet, you know what I mean?
- I'm bored by it.
- The bread is like
perfectly toasted, though.
- Better call Keith.
- Hello, Keith!
- (laughing) Hello,
Collin, how's it going?
- Joan's on Third was kind of a bummer.
- Let me make it up to you.
You're gonna go to
Doughboys, which is nearby.
It's also on third.
- Doughboys cafe on third, remember that.
- This is an exquisite peanut
butter and jelly sandwich.
I believed it's either
fried, grilled, or baked.
A whole bunch of stuff is going into it.
You're gonna love it, or
at least we hope you do.
- So, we just tried to go
into Doughboys to get their
gourmet peanut butter
chocolate banana sandwich,
which is, I heard, amazing.
They wouldn't allow us to film,
so we're gonna get those joints to-go,
and I guess, head back to the orange van.
- Literally, what they do, is
they take all the ingredients,
peanut butter, chocolate, jelly, bananas.
They stuff it all together on the bread.
They dip it in egg batter,
and then they grill that.
They take that sandwich, they
bake it a little bit longer,
so it bakes together,
and they serve it to you.
That's why it takes so long.
- Oh, my God.
I will say, that this
thing is so overwhelming.
Like I don't even know what I'm tasting.
- I'm into it though, and
I love the banana aspect.
- You know what the problem is, guys?
- What?
- The peanut butter to jelly ratio.
- One thing I know, is that
this won't taste as good cold,
so let's get a hot one
back to Keith, right now.
- Here we go, here we go.
Sandwich!
- Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
Guys, did you have a good adventure?
- Sure.
- Yeah.
It was good.
- It was alright.
- Well, they did it.
Those feasties feasted the
fuck out of those sandwiches.
And they brought me one!
Which means in the end,
all you viewers, are jelly.
Wait a minute though, wasn't
the Mendocino Farms one
like, the really good one?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, that was the best.
- Then why didn't you bring me that one?
(laughing) Powderpuff girls?
Why is that your go-to?
You a big powderpuff girl fan, Steven?
Alright.